how strong is that hair no seriously can
anyone tell me how strong that hair is
we caught up with Anastasia at the
circus of Horrors in London to find out
where her hair-raising talent came from
I first discovered that I had really
strong hair when boys used to pull on my
plants and when I was a kid and we used
to do a little tug of war in the
playground
everything you see in the circus of
Horrors is 100% real and there isn't
like a metal plate to drilled into my
skull or anything like that and when
Anastasia isn't hanging out of the
circus she of course relaxes by towing
trucks I think it's easier for people to
imagine that there's a trick to it but
it is exactly why it is I am pulling the
track with my hair so the question is
how can she do this without getting
seriously hurt
good question Adam hair is surprisingly
strong a lock of a hundred hairs can
hold up to 22 pounds that's ten
kilograms so a full head of hair which
is about a hundred thousand strands can
support 12 tonnes that's two fully grown
African elephants suspended from your
hair the strength of human hair is
especially amazing considering that the
hairs are mostly made of dead cells but
those dead cells contain keratin the
long thin keratin filaments are arranged
along the length of the hair giving it
tensile strength which means it's
resistant to pulling it apart the
problem is that if any one strand of
hair takes too much of the load it will
snap so Anastasia's had to very
carefully braid her hair
so the load is distributed as evenly as
possible that's why you need to take
such a long time brushing the hair and
making sure that all the poo is even
across all the follicles and in that
take more tension we'll pull out
Anastasia's also wetted her hair which
means that her hair is gonna be a little
more elastic so that when she pulls on
the truck it's not one instant force
it's spread out more gradually and this
makes her hair less likely to break
from the science of hair follicles to
the science of air molecules